they definitely have to find a way to  engage the European citizens and that  this is a project that's in their best  interests I think for example the  importance of banking union they very  simple they made a mistake calling it a  banking union they should have called it  a depositors Union they want to  stabilize the banking system for the  benefit of depositors if you notice in  the United States the Federal Deposit  Insurance Corporation doesn't have the  word bankers in its name so they're  things like that that they have to turn  the table on this is not being done just  for the sake of having a monetary union  and economic union for the benefit of a  lot of people in Brussels it's being  done to create a platform for growth for  the citizens of Europe and that's the  kind of narrative that they've got to  move on to  you